good afternoon my name is Grayson Howard
I'm a sophomore English major here at
Hillsdale College and I will be
introducing our speaker today
Christopher Caldwell is a contributing
editor at the Claremont Review of Books
and a contributing opinion writer for
The New York Times a graduate of
Hillsdale Harvard College his essays
columns and reviews appear in The Wall
Street Journal the New York Times Book
Review The Spectator Financial Times the
Claremont Review of Books and numerous
other publications he is the author of
reflections on the revolution and Europe
immigration Islam and the West and the
age of entitlement America since the 66
TS forthcoming January 2020
please welcome Christopher Caldwell
gosh well thank you Grayson I would like
to thank everyone at Hillsdale for
coming it but particularly the people
from the the Center for constructive
alternatives Matt Bell
I want to thank Kim Ellsworth for for
organizing things but and so I guess
that what I'm doing here is is is trying
to figure out with you whether Swedish
socialism constitutes a constructive
alternative maybe we can start by saying
there are two basic ways I think to
think about socialism the first is as a
doctrine related to communism and among
followers of Karl Marx socialism is
often just another word for communism
you know you talk about the Union of
Soviet Socialist Republics but more
usually socialism reflects an outcome
after Marxist revolutionaries have had
to make compromises or accommodate
reality it's the sort of government a
socialist government you get when you
when when revolutionaries are thwarted
by entrenched powers of some some kind
or by the weakness of their own
revolutionary leaders or by popular
dislike of it socialism described this
way tends to be unpopular but there's so
so so those who promote socialism tend
to look at it in the second way the
second way to look at socialism is as
its own separate thing
that has nothing to do with communism
and in this in in this understanding
socialism is just carrying out some old
and time-honored human impulse you know
such as charity or the Golden Rule or
Christian ethics except in a kind of an
up-to-date
way that adjusts to modern conditions
and this is the kind of socialism that's
the more popular of the two and I think
that this is the kind of socialism that
that today's Millennials or young people
are talking about when they identify
themselves as socialists in such
strikingly high numbers I think many of
us have seen the poll that was carried
out by Reason magazine in 2014 that
showed that 42 percent of Millennials
call themselves socialists are happy to
call themselves socialists I think I'm
less surprised or alarmed by that poll
than many people if you really look at
it very closely
only 16 percent of these so-called
socialists realized that government
means or that socialism means government
ownership of the means of production 64
percent of these socialists say they
would prefer that the economy be run on
a free-market basis and 55 percent of
them aspire to start their own
businesses okay so III think that that
the kids like this are they would not
choose to live in the Soviet Union of
the 1950s or or the Albania of the 1960s
but the problem is while they're not
ready to fight for socialism they might
be convinced to vote for people who want
to fight for socialism they seem to want
they seem to want a nicer version of our
own system which in itself is not an
indefensible desire and they've lately
taken to calling that desire socialism
and that's why people like Bernie
Sanders point to Sweden and particularly
Sweden and say the 1970s as a model and
and certainly it's a it's a it's a it's
a child it is a real challenge I mean
you can say that ABBA
and Bjorn Borg are more attractive
figures than marx and engels right but I
think the argument is about more than
that Sweden in the 1970s actually seemed
to square a lot of circles in in in
terms of policy it was at the time the
most egalitarian country in Western
Europe but it was also the fourth
richest country per capita in the world
it had very high almost total working
class union membership but at the same
time it had Europe's perhaps Europe's
best developed culture of
entrepreneurship so there would seem to
be things worth studying and a lot of
people back then said well we could do
that if only we could figure out what
this Swedish model was and follow it
ourselves and that leads to the two
questions that will preoccupy me for the
next half an hour say which is what is
this Swedish model and why do we think
that it can be replicated so the things
I'm going to talk about in the next half
hour are first the the origins of
Swedish socialism in the 19th century
its relationship to Marxism its early
development up into the 1930s then the
kind of Golden Age of Swedish socialism
running between especially after the 30s
but especially after the 60s and into
the the 1980s which showed these
surprising strengths that I talk about
like um like an ability to coexist with
entrepreneurship then its decline in the
1990s and then a new twist on Swedish
socialism now I would like to ask to
what degree is it responsible for
Sweden's immigration problem because I
do think that when you think of Sweden
today the one thing you must understand
is that it has a uniquely disruptive
immigration problem even by European
standards
and then finally I will get to this
question of whether the Swedish model is
viable even for Sweden and if if so
whether it is replicable for the rest of
us okay now if there's any place in the
world where socialism ought to work the
way Bernie Sanders describes it that is
where it ought to be thought of as
ancient wisdom rather than Marxist
ideology it's Sweden I mean if you go
back to the beginning - you know Sweden
had unlike other places in Europe it had
no contact with Rome it was a total
stranger to the kind of complex
differentiated articulated society that
Roman conquest always brought in its
wake I mean so I mean there are their
primitive places all over over Europe
but but but Sweden didn't even have any
contact with this complex kind of
society it didn't even have feudalism it
was primitive it was it was uncultured
it didn't its literature figures in the
most marginal way in this great
blossoming of European literature's that
that covers almost every European
country you know from Germany to France
to Spain - to italy to poland to the
netherlands and it was really poor so
you know in the late 19th century 20
percent of the population of sweden
emigrated and i mind since much of it is
to this part of the world there are
probably children of that many children
of that immigration in this room so i
don't have to explain that to you but
there were upsides to this being
downtrodden you know sweden had a a
strong idea of equality it had a
powerful idea of social solidarity and
community of the sort that you might
associate only with kind of
military cultures like Sparta you know
the historian Sheri Berman who is
general highly sympathetic to to Swedish
socialism she notes the way that you
know even in the late nineteenth century
Sweden was neither industrial more
democratic and what that means is that
the the Swedish Workers Party which is
the forerunner to the party that created
the Swedish socialist system they could
claim to have really brought about
industrialism and universal suffrage in
a kind of a unique way I mean most but
by the time most socialist parties
appear on the scene seen that system is
already all set up so that most
socialist parties are basically just
divvying up the spoils in a way that is
more favorable to them the Swedish
Socialist Party had a was was really
closer to the roots of Swedish society
okay
nonetheless all right as people became
aware in the 1920s and and the 1930s
what the Russian Revolution was actually
doing socialists in Sweden aroused the
same kind of distrust that they did
everywhere else they were attacked as
secret communists they were accused of
carrying more about Swedes of certain
classes than they were about you know
defending Swedes against foreigners and
in the 1928 elections the Swedish
socialists were just wiped out which is
what was happening to socialist parties
all over Europe at the time but the
Swedes went back to the drawing board
and in 1932 they campaigned on a very
different idea they campaigned that
Sweden ought to be what they called a
folk hema or people's home they even
spoke of they even called this national
socialism and I don't say this to accuse
them of being Nazis really as some of
their political appeal
do but we should know okay that in
Sweden today when the kind of historians
we might refer to as politically correct
talk about socialism's early years they
find it embarrassing and a little bit
creepy I mean I what I will say is that
that Swedish socialists were not like
their contemporaries in France and Spain
in France and Spain socialists really
were trying to create a kind of like an
international world working class
solidarity what Sweden was doing was a
lot more similar to what FDR was doing
in this country that it was if it was a
socialism it was a socialism that was at
Raul was was tied to a great deal of
national feeling and even nationalism
and that's why I think that nationalism
is why the Swedish socialists were the
only European Socialist Party to survive
the 1930s in power okay and they were
aided in that by having some really
extraordinary leaders okay so that began
what we can call say that Golden Age of
Swedish socialism and it's an
interesting thing with only a couple of
minor hiccups and with only a couple of
minor interruptions Sweden had only
three prime ministers between the early
1930s and the late 1980s and I'll go
over them briefly
you had peril being Hansen which who was
the the sort of the FDR of Sweden he
came to power in 1932 ruled till the end
of World War two kept Sweden neutral in
the war which will be important later on
and he was kind of you know and created
this Foulke hem ideology then there was
his successor was toga airlander this
was the great divisor of big of big
socialist programs kind of like Sweden's
equivalent of
BJ but if you imagine LBJ ruling for an
entire generation you get an idea of
what the what an impact toga airlander
had and then finally there was Olaf
Palma who came to first came to power in
1969 and ruled most of the time until he
was assassinated mysteriously in in 1986
he is a tendency we didn't have in this
country he's what maybe like the United
States would have been like if say Ted
Kennedy instead of Ronald Reagan had
been president in the 1980s so Hansen
air launder and palma these are kind of
giants of european socialism and and and
and over that period it is hard to think
of another triumvirate who held such an
important position for so long and the
only one I can think of actually is Ted
Williams call Yastrzemski and Jim Rice
in left field for the Boston Red Sox all
three in the same period of time ok 30s
to the 80s all three of them in the Hall
of Fame we can talk about the Red Sox
instead if anyone would like but but
anyway under under those men anyhow the
Social Democratic Party dominated Sweden
we're talking about from the end of the
Hoover administration to the end of the
Reagan administration we're talking
about from the The Wall Street Crash you
know and in the Great Depression until
the Internet age and so if you think of
you know so think of these people in
there with their American analogues if
you had FDR LBJ and Ted Kennedy given
half a century unlimited resources and
zero opposition to build their own kind
of socialism what would it would look
like ok and I'll give you some examples
of what it did look like let's start
with one typical and kind of really
ambitious program that would be very
consequential for the future of Sweden
in the early 1960s airlander declared
that all Swedes had a right to modern
sort of humane housing and that he would
build 1 million units of housing
now given that Sweden had only 6 million
people at the time that's a ton of
housing
it created a glut of building it drove
up the construction work workers
salaries and so it did some things that
people liked but it created problems ok
most of these this was called the
million program for the number of units
he was going to build most of these
million program housing units they were
apartments
in big complexes on the outskirts of
town and and you know Swedes you know
Sweden has a relatively small population
about the same population as Michigan
but it's twice as big as Michigan so
it's got it actually get a lot of room
okay so Swedes don't have to live that
way they don't tend to like living in
apartments and the result was that a lot
of these apartments built in the 60s
were either empty or in very low demand
in the future and that's going to be an
important consideration which I'll bring
come back to in a couple of minutes but
there were impressive things about or
seemingly impressive things about this
Swedish welfare state and things that
things where where people seem to be
able to have their cake and eat it too
okay first of all it seemed to offer
generous wages and in equality without
denting anybody's work ethic you know
and generous welfare plans second it had
huge top income tax rates but it didn't
seem to limit entrepreneurship at all
and in fact as I said Sweden was for
much of the last century one of the most
entrepreneurial and innovative countries
on earth okay so you had couple
companies like in the old days you had
you know Electrolux vacuum cleaners you
had Volvo you had saab saab was
originally a an airplane company Sweden
by the way I believe is the only country
of its size that makes its own fighter
jets then you had you know retailers I
mean the Swedes revolutionised retail we
didn't realize it until the global
economy started but I mean companies
like IKEA H&M those are old companies in
Sweden but they've really made quite an
impression in in our part of the world
and then on top of that you have the
newer high-tech companies like Spotify
or Ericsson phones I mean it's a very
impressive business culture it took the
young there's a young Kurdish Swedish
economist Timo son and son and ie whose
family emigrated to Sweden at the turn
of the century to point out that that
this reputation for for quality its
reputation for for being an
entrepreneurial place is not an illusion
the reputation for being able to unite
entrepreneurship and socialism kind of
is because if you really look at if you
look at the 1950s as the time when when
the Swedish welfare state started
operating at full throttle then almost
all of these companies were either
already there
before it started or they were founded
after it really began to decline which I
would say came at the start of the 1990s
and I'll talk a little bit about how it
declined the Swedish welfare state the
Swedish socialist system was
surprisingly
disciplined it and that's how they
succeeded in doing things but that no
one thought were possible for a Sweden
for a socialist system but after the
1980s Sweden really began to do what
what run of the mill socialist countries
are all supposed to do if you you know
if you believe the models which is it
let
it's benefits run beyond the the taxes
that it was raising to pay for them and
and and that's a run-of-the-mill problem
but there were there were problems
specific to Sweden too they had a
complicated scheme of what they call
wage earner investment funds which was a
which was a sort of tax that was meant
to be used to slowly buy out private
firms and and and turn them into public
ones and that that wound up sewing a lot
of insecurity I think the country was
also a bit caught by surprise by the
competition that the end of the Cold War
had unleashed so I think it lost a lot
of its shipbuilding which was a major
industry to foreign countries like like
Korea but basically between 1990 and
1994 its Sweden's GNP contracted by 6
percent and its level of employment fell
by 12 percent it's it's one of the
largest peacetime contractions that we
know of in any single country there are
global downturns but this is just one
country just sort of like falling
through the floor at a time of general
global prosperity and by that time
Sweden was dealing with another big
problem which is immigration now I'll
talk about that for a little bit when I
was writing a book about about
immigration in Europe several years ago
I you know ever since then I've been
I've been asked you know what country in
Europe is really in the worst shape you
know faced with immigration and I never
have any hesitation and answering Sweden
Sweden's immigration problems are maybe
not quite as obvious as the ones in in
say France and and and they need to take
they take a little bit of tracing there
their origins go back to the middle of
the last century but I'll I'd like to
explain why I think Sweden has such a a
big problem Sweden was
officially neutral in World War 2 which
means that its prosperity was not
interrupted by the war but in fact it
was also a big supplier of iron ore in
particular and the machinery to a lesser
degree to the to the Nazi government
so when 1945 came Sweden was really well
capitalized and this was a time when all
of Europe needed to be rebuilt and
Sweden was the only advanced Western
country besides the United States that
had its entire industrial base intact
and so Sweden was going to get rich rich
rich I mean in in retrospect Sweden's
post-war growth rates there was
something inevitable about them all
right
Sweden grew four percent a year between
the end of the Second World War and the
oil crisis of the of 1973 which is and
it's from that I think that a lot of
this idea of the Swedish welfare state
as a real miracle came about in fact
sweet Sweden grew 7% a year in in in the
1960s which was a sort of a a Chinese
rate you know but the economy was so hot
that Sweden needed labour and it just
needed more hands to keep these
factories running and so the result was
a series of labour agreements with
foreign countries along the lines of the
gastarbeiter programs the the guest
worker programs that Germany had you
know so Sweden started by offering
special deals to Italy and Hungary and
1947 and then in the 60s when it worked
through those workforces they they wound
up offering the same to Yugoslavia and
Turkey Finn's there are many many Finn's
or Turkey our Swedish speaking they were
coming in throughout the same period and
it was this this emigration was quite a
success and the problem was that they
couldn't shut it off
and even when the economy began to go
south okay this is because of certain
moral considerations in foreign policy
Sweden had always had a you know it's
largely you could call it a pacifist
country they didn't participate in World
War one or World War two but just
because you don't want to get rekt and
war doesn't mean you necessarily
renounce your aspiration to shape the
world I mean but so Sweden has always
had a kind of a crusading humanitarian
side and perhaps it's a way of atoning
for its cooperation with Nazi Germany
and in World War two it became much more
demonstrative about this side of itself
in in 1968 there was some persecution of
Jews in in in in Poland and many left
Sweden took them Sweden took all the
Greeks who were or it offered spots to
all the Greeks who felt themselves
persecuted by the government of the
colonel's
you know between 1968 and I believe it
was 74 it took a lot of people in from
Chile it was a main destination for
leftists who felt they had to leave
Chile after the coup by General Pinochet
in I believe 73 but then after olaf
Palma who was a much more after Olaf
Palma came to power he's the third of
the of the leaders that I mentioned he
was a much more anti-american sort of
progressive internationalist and when he
came to power I think Sweden lost to the
habit of saying no altogether it was
then that Swedish politicians started
referring to their country as a quote
moral superpower unquote so Sweden
Sweden took refugees from the Somali war
from the Bosnian war in the middle of
middle of the 90s early 90s they took
took refugees from Algeria
they took Iraqi
and afghans and the new in the new
century and then four years ago in 2015
when you know if you remember when
refugees from the war in Syria began
began marching into Europe the
Scandinavian countries were most people
believed extraordinarily generous and
I'll give you the number of refugees
they took Denmark processed 21,000
refugees asylum was applications Norway
processed 31,000 Finland processed 30
2002 160 mm okay now and this has turned
the country of Sweden upside down many
European countries have tried to limit
immigration immigration over the years
on the grounds that they wouldn't know
where to put them
I mean this is not a problem that Sweden
had at least at first because it had all
this housing that had built in places
outside of major cities so in in in
housing projects like ranked up in in
places like rinkeby and Tensta outside
of Stockholm these places tended to fill
up with foreigners now we should not
exaggerate the role of the Million
Programme I mean immigration by now has
outstripped the ability even of Sweden
to provide crisis housing and since 9
since 2015 it seems that every you know
summer camp and and sort of like
offseason hotel and and gymnasium floor
has been used to house immigrant beds
but until recently there were places to
hide immigrants and this is a very
important thing if you want to
understand why Sweden has taken so many
migrants in Stockholm you don't notice
that you're living in a highly diverse
metropolitan area in the single European
country that has been most overwhelmed
by migration in fact it looks like a low
migration country
but in fact it's not a low migration
country it's a segregated country and
what you have in you know is is the
usual paradox of segregation which is
the more segregated a country is the
bigger a problem it has but the more
harmonious it looks and so that's where
you are with Sweden all over Europe now
there's talk about how if migration
isn't slowed down this or that country
is going to lose its culture etc in
Sweden it's already too late for that
and in the numbers in Sweden are really
extraordinary
Sweden's population is 19 percent
foreign-born it is 32 percent of foreign
origin more than 30 percent of the
babies are born to foreign mothers right
now Sweden's Muslim population is 8
percent according to the research a Pew
Research Center if immigration continues
at the present rate in the year 2050
which is 31 years from now Sweden will
be 30 percent Muslim if refugee flows
were to stop today and there would be
zero migration for the next 30 years Pew
projects that Sweden would still be 21
percent Muslim in the year 2050 and this
is important when we think about about
Swedish socialism because the
peculiarities that made Sweden special
are disappearing and these I think are
the peculiarities that made it possible
to sustain socialism for so long they're
so really radical parties have begun to
crop up in Sweden they've begun to get
double-digit results in elections and
what they generally complain about is
first primarily the size of immigration
but also the effect of the size of
immigration on what remains of the
socialist welfare state so Tina said on
dolly the
The Economist whose insightful remarks
on entrepreneurship I I mentioned just a
second ago I mean he pointed out that
the population of Swedes of Swedish or
eighth origin is roughly stable at 7.7
million but that the country as a whole
due to emigration is now over now has
over 10 million people and it's growing
at a rate as fast as Bangladesh you know
son and I he is a very interesting guy
it's a very mischievous economist and he
loves to like throw out these factoids
this is where one other thing he's done
is he's sort of like tallied the net
benefit of per migrant of migration and
if he's found that it's a it's a net
loss I mean he's a I should just say
he's a he's a very fascinating guy he's
he's much criticized on on talk shows
and by by by proper intellectuals but he
self-published a book on this subject of
migration from which I draw some of
these statistics and it became the the
number one bestseller in Sweden for
quite a while but anyway I would say I
would say that maybe in fact the
greatest gift of immigration to Sweden
has been a set of immigrant
intellectuals who have kind of revealed
the Swedes to themselves or revealed
things about their new country that that
the Swedes themselves were had a hard
time noticing so I've already mentioned
Tino son and I he but I'd I would like
to mention in particular the economist
and politician Mauricio Rojas because I
find his model so interesting they
taught me so much about Sweden when I
was studying and I met him about 15
years ago when I was writing a lot about
immigration and and and Sweden's growing
inner cities and Rojas was a figure he
was the closest thing in in Sweden to
say Jack Kemp
okay he was the guy who was sort of
testing out the appeal of free market
ideas to non-traditional voters and
Rojas arrived in in in Sweden as you may
guess from his name from from Chile as a
young leftist in the in the 1970s and
you know he was a guy he's a refugee
from a from a country that had tried had
put all its effort into building
socialism you know and and and and the
socialist project there had met
tremendous resistance from the you know
not just from the middle class but
eventually from the army okay and so he
suddenly wound up in this in in this
country where you know like a hundred
percent of the people seem to think that
socialism was a was a great deal and and
and and that everyone should imitate it
and so he he began to sort of like
wonder well why why why wasn't Chile
able to to imitate it you know you know
why couldn't everyone imitate it and the
usual response of people in Sweden was
well you didn't get the program exactly
right and every deal in detail you know
you have to Reno Monnaie the workers to
the workers and councils biannually
instead of and sort of stuff like that
you know and you know how a lot of
utopia's are this way I mean they have a
lot of promise but you you know you get
one tiny detail wrong and you wind up in
a in a civil war you know but but so
when people were talking to him that way
Rojas said no it has to be it has to be
something deeper than that you know that
that can't be the way that Latin America
is going to get Sweden Swedish style
socialism because in fact that's not the
way Sweden got Swedish style socialism
and in his work as an economic historian
and and and and and a bit less so but in
his career as a free-market politician
he went slowly through Sweden's long
history and its culture
there's sort of some of the things I've
been discussing this afternoon and that
I think was really the right place to
look the most important thing he
discovered was how widely Sweden
diverged from the history of other
countries it was a particular place a
lot of its particularity
came from its peasant origins you know
it had this tremendous tradition of
egalitarian that we've been talking
about but it didn't have much of a
tradition of of individual rights that
was a strange thing about it then there
were other peculiarities that came from
its homogeneity and and for instance
there was a there's a sense of shame in
not working and not carrying you know
like your share of the load and this
homogeneity the Rojas also found
extended to opinion you know Swedes
expected to agree with one another and
you know and that made its difference
its development very different from
other Western European nations a lot of
European nations developed as a way of
finding a compromise between clashing
interests you know classes or ignoble
houses or even nations I mean the United
Kingdom is the classic example of that
but actually Sweden didn't really have
many competing interests and as such
there were a whole there are lots of
things that were typical of the West
that it didn't really have in quite the
same way like you know freelance
intellectuals you know an obsession for
with a free press I mean Sweden Sweden
both radio and television were state
monopolies into the 1980s it didn't have
a Western idea of the separation of
powers I mean because you don't the goal
was not arguing the goal was sort of
agreeing and so Rojas looked at these
things and he said well of course you
can build socialism in a place like that
but most places aren't like that
and he asked people to try to understand
how
strange Swedish socialism was by asking
them to look that sort of more normal
less controversial Swedish things and he
took the example of a piece of Swedish
modern furniture like a table and I'll
close with with with the conclusion he
drew from it easy
he said the Swedes look at a table and
they they're so provincial that they
think it's just a normal table but but
Rojas having grown up in Chile could see
actually how different this Swedish
table was and I will quote from an essay
of his he says the fascinating austerity
and naturalism of Nordic design the
Swedish passion for simplicity and the
natural the evident dislike of purely
ornamental or ostentatious elements the
illegitimate II of luxury and a very
sober relation to money all these are
expressions of a culture bearing the
mark of a still unchallenged peasant
heritage in which is deemed detestable
not only aristocratic pump or
individualistic petty bourgeois swagger
but also any attempt to be noticeably
different from the mass of the people or
to act without some kind of collective
cover and I think with that
Rojas had had discovered the solution to
the problem that we've spent the last
half hour discussing I mean Swedish
socialism arose from peculiarities of
Sweden's national character not only
that it relied on social and economic
capital that had been built up before
Sweden became socialist and this was
this was not a program that could be
replicated elsewhere no matter how long
one studied it in fact it was not a
program at all it was a it was a culture
if you have that kind of culture it will
be it'll probably be pretty easy to
build socialism but if you don't you'd
probably be wiser not
try thank you very much thank you mr.
Caldwell we now have time for Q&A so
please come to the microphone if you
have a question
hello mr. Caldwell I think language is
important especially if we're going to
convince people today who want socialism
here that we shouldn't have it and you
made quite a case for a collectivist
mindset in Sweden along with their
homogeneous society until recently but
many of the other speakers here would
have said that Sweden really doesn't
have socialism because the government
doesn't own the agents or means of
production so how would you reconcile
your calling what Sweden has socialism
as opposed to those who would say that
they really don't that's a good question
one is it's very egalitarian it's highly
redistributed the other is there is a
government role in in in in many of
Sweden's largest industries and I think
the the goal of certainly the airlander
government was I believe as they put it
was to D commodify social goods so
you're right it was not and that's why
the reason I think that we're talking
about it today it was not a full-blown
you know Soviet style
experiment in in in in in rejiggering a
a society but it went very far it went
farther in the direction of
redistribution than probably any other
european society and that was what I
think people meant by that word yes
thank you very much for a very
interesting perspective on Sweden we had
an exchange student from Sweden in 1974
Annika and she was so Swedish blonde
hair you know beautiful eyes when she
walked down the streets of our tiny
little town in northern Michigan people
would just stop and stare the people in
Rogers City thought that they knew a lot
about Sweden because they hell it had
excuse me saunas anyway my feeling about
the politicians today who are pushing on
socialism is they don't want us to be
Americans Americans are unique Americans
like being wealthy we want to be wealthy
that's why we worked so hard and what do
we do with our wealth we try to make
other people happy we work hard and when
I was young my mother would say you're
not French you're not
you're an American what do you think
about that well I think that that I was
making a pretty similar point the the
different different countries have
different cultures when you live in a
vast and varied culture like our own
where a lot of people actually don't
know each other and and there's not a
lot of communal provision of security
you will need actually to aspire to
accumulate money I think that that need
was less pressing for people who came
from a from a Swedish culture or at
least it was perceived as less as less
pressing I think that it's become more
pressing as their society has globalized
as there are lots of you know like new
things that leave them on you know
uneasy and and I think that's one of the
reasons one of the reasons why Sweden is
changing one of the reasons why you know
the Swedes themselves are growing more
skeptical about their welfare state
thank you so much for coming here I
myself have never hosted a Swedish
exchange student but I do have a
question for you so clearly mass
immigration into Sweden negatively
affected Swedish social and public
institutions and my question for you
would be what effects do you believe
mass immigration into our own country
will have on our institutions in society
and if those effects are negative how
does the threat of mass immigration
really square up to a few socialist
politicians running for national office
yeah
it immigration has been I mean I think
immigration is disruptive wherever it
happens it has benefits to wherever it
happens but the balance is different in
Europe because in most European
countries and and and I'm sure this is
true in Sweden it's not considered okay
to have people come into your country
who cannot have access to benefits as
soon as immigrants make themselves known
they are eligible for a lot of benefits
and that's you know there's been a big
outcry and it's been and it's been uh
it's probably more limited than it has
been in recent waves of memory of
migration but but if you're a Swedish
migrant if you're a migrant coming to
Sweden you get a check okay
now that means that they can exist on
the fringes of society forever okay
they don't have there's not the need to
assimilate the way there are I mean in
the American system of tolerating
illegal immigration where people are
kind of living at the margins it's it
has its imperfections obviously from one
thing that creates illegality etc but it
does force people into the workplace and
I think the workplace is the main place
that people get assimilated and that
does not happen to the same degree in
Sweden so I think that's the main way in
which in which Sweden is being more mega
and negatively impacted than here
there's another issue that comes up in
Europe and that is the fact you're
immigrants generally okay it's changed a
bit in the last 10 years or 15 years but
the great pool of immigrants in in most
of these Western societies come from
adjacent cultures so the tone of the
tone of American
immigration is set by Latin Americans
the tone of European immigration is set
by North African and and Middle Eastern
Muslims this is a subjective thing but I
would say that the gap between American
and Latin American culture is extremely
narrow compared to the gap between
European and Muslim culture ok that's a
problem it's a bit less of a problem in
Sweden because you have such a big
diversity of of Muslim cultures so it's
not like you have as you do in Germany
say a huge Turkish subculture that's
like a country within a country or you
know Algerians in France or Moroccans in
in in in in the Netherlands but it is a
much more it does create expectations of
the country and of its institutions and
there's not time to go into it but you
can you can consider the you know the
the debates over how long meet in public
schools where you know probably a third
of the of the kids are foreign-born and
you have a measure of how it how
migration actually puts a bigger stress
on Sweden I think than it does on us
sorry so sort of echoing the first
question you know evading the question
of whether or not something is or is not
talking about socialism I know that
Norway and Sweden tend to have sort of
like Canada America type comparison we
talk about Swedish economist getting
avian economies writing I know the
Norwegians really pride themselves on
having handled an immigration crisis a
lot better and that they have famously
oil money that keeps them floating so
I'm wondering if you could expound a
little bit on contrasting Norwegian
Social Democratic concepts and Swedish
Social Democratic concepts especially as
Sweden has become more I should say
socially democratic and less straight-up
socialist right so why is it that like
how do those two come together like you
know Sweden's obviously a dumpster fire
and Norway kind of prides itself on not
being a dumpster fire and it seems to be
the only difference is there like a
dumpster fire right
so yeah so like is it like other than
handling immigration well and having a
ton of reserved oil you know is there
something magical about Norway I mean
they both have the Protestant work ethic
as like Santa Josh would say yeah did
you just expound on that a little bit
because I find Norway to be an
interesting contrast yeah I'm not sure I
can't expand on that because that Rho
would require a greater knowledge of the
of the Norwegian immigrant system then
then I actually have I mean a contrast
that I have noted is between that I
wrote quite a lot about in past years
was between Denmark and Sweden because
it's very it's it's very obvious where
you know malmö in in Sweden meets
Copenhagen and in Denmark they're kind
of since there was a bridge built there
a couple of decades ago and so they've
become kind of like twin cities and and
Denmark has since 2001 had a really
great Kony and anti-immigrant regime
it's not a well let's say it's not it's
not a an immigrant ban or anything like
that but there are a series of laws
meant to prevent things like chain
migration that is sort of like you know
groups of migrants importing Brides from
their villages who you know like then
have children who bring Brides from
their villages and the children being
brought up and in the foreign language
this happens a lot with people from
Pakistan and-and-and from eastern Turkey
the the Danish attempt to limit these
things has resulted in a drastically
different social profile I think I mean
that I think Denmark's foreign-born is
percentages is well under 10% and
Sweden's is that 20% I don't think
Denmark is considered a really
intolerant country but they have a very
different relationship to migration now
the
um then Sweden did then Sweden does and
and so I think that's the that's the
comparison I've looked at I'm sorry I
can't tell you more about Norway I have
a question regarding the Swedish
elections of 1928 and 1932 and the
distinction you see between the
perception of socialism in 1928 and in
1932 and the rise of the folk I'm can
that be attributed to or is it partially
attributable to the ripple effects of
the international recession that goes on
in the 1930s you know the Great Great
Depression in the United States and the
financial insolvency of Germany and
France and Britain to some extent yes I
think that's a very it's a very troubled
time and there are a lot of you know
there are a lot of the closer one looks
at Sweden the more one sees
peculiarities I mean it's it's it's it's
tempting to sort of like look at all
these as some you know there are things
that were happening in Europe but the
countries were quite different in Sweden
when you think of it is really across a
rather large sea it's you know from the
mainland of Europe and so one thing that
happened in when you talk about the you
know the transition from from just a
purely socialist program to a kind of a
socialist nationalist program is that
Sweden didn't have a sort of a real
right-wing that had claimed that
nationalist
mantle and I think it's because I think
it's because in World War one Sweden was
neutral and in fact a lot of the you
know what we think of as the right wing
movements of the 1920s these were you
know demobilized people who had been in
the military they had a great strong
feeling of solidarity with the people
they had been fighting in the trenches
with and a strong feeling of having been
betrayed by their government I'm
there were countries like France and
Germany lost three or four million
people and you know in in the First
World War and so nationalism tended to
be claimed by those people there was no
one claiming nationalism in the same way
in Sweden and so when the crash came
which brought I think an increase in
unemployment in in in in Sweden as it
did everywhere else there was not a
ready-made you know political polarity
between you know the the Marxists here
and the and the street fighting sort of
like paramilitaries there there was a
lot more fluidity and and I think that
that made the Social Democrats more
capable of you know forming a of making
an attractive offer to the voting public
we have time for one more question thank
you for your talk you mentioned earlier
that there were a few prosperous
companies that started in Sweden such as
Saab and IKEA and I was wondering did
they start in the socialist time period
and if they did how are they able to
thrive right so that that's what I was
um that's uh I I might have must have
been unclear because I mentioned the
Econo the economist Pino Sun and ie then
one of the things he said is that
there's a group of that that actually
while you had socialism and while you
had entrepreneurialism they didn't date
from the same time they kind of lived
side by side they weren't part of the
same system and what he was saying is
that you know let's say Electrolux and
IKEA and H&M came out of I think H and I
Kia and H&M were both founded during the
you know Second World War when the whole
you know when the rest of Europe was not
founding companies at all you know that
but uh but they came before the high
tide of socialism you know what I mean
and that Spotify and knows other you
know Ericsson and those those high tech
companies they came after the decline of
socialism so while it still
you might still call Sweden a social
democratic country today it's not a it's
not confidently so or noticeably that
much more so than other European
countries so his argument which I
endorse is that you had a period of
entrepreneurship in a period of social
democracy and then another period of
entrepreneurship Thank You mr. Caldwell
thank you
[Applause]